can you tell when people have accents
absolutely oh you got a strong one
hi my name is cece bell and el deafo is
the story of my childhood
and adjusting to
a sudden hearing loss
[Music]
this is my own unique personal story
there are so many ways to be
a deaf person some people
might be like me and
wear hearing aids and lip read some
might not wear hearing aids at all and
prefer sign language is anyone here deaf
or hard of hearing
that's you susie
it's really important for me that the
kids who watch the show
are experiencing it the way i
experienced it you can read the book and
get the sense of what speech is like for
example from the speech balloons but you
can watch the show
and actually hear is it working
the audio design was really tough i want
to be able to explain to hearing people
what this is like
hey cece
[Music]
my character on the show cannot see the
person's mouth move
then the audio is pretty much clear
there's a little bit of distortion
because we're trying to
share with viewers
what it might sound like to wear hearing
aids
hey kids you know the truth let's break
into two teams for some major kickball
action but then there are situations
that happen where
that comprehension just goes away maybe
the lights get turned off
before
a character faces away 206
i think by recreating that experience
it's sort of a reminder
of how to be
with a person that doesn't hear very
well you know don't shout
remember that the person needs to see
your face you know be empathetic think
about what it would feel like and this
is a very direct
way to help kids
understand what that feels like
[Music]
you